algunas vosotros nos habéis preguntado
por las diferencias que existen entre
tez cruz y donald trump no estoy de
acuerdo con su política de matar a bart
pero si apruebo su política de parte del
círculo los dos púgiles que con mayor
probabilidad de victoria están luchando
por hacerse con la nominación del
partido republicano hoy vamos a verlo
soy enrique couto y esto es visual
político
los dos candidatos están viviendo un
proceso realmente reñido de momento
trampa por delante pero cruz aún tiene
muchas posibilidades de acabar
obteniendo la nominación y de hecho las
últimas semanas está recibiendo el apoyo
del establishment del partido
necesitaremos un candidato popular que
sepa manejar a la prensa un líder que
haga exactamente lo que dedicamos ambos
candidatos son conocidos por ser muy
radicales y mantienen posturas comunes
en muchos campos como puede ser la
inmigración donde ambos son pro
deportaciones pero limitaciones pero
muros o en su lucha con lo que os
denomina el cártel de washington las
gentes políticas también en la lucha
contra el isis y el fundamentalismo
islámico tienen posiciones muy similares
pero en otros campos sus caminos se
separan por completo hoy vamos a
destacar los tres campos principales
donde donald trump y test cruz son
irreconciliables
según muñeco de donald trump hola qué
pasada que hace finge ser republicano
que el dinero no es el más importante de
todos la visión que tienen sobre el
gobierno sobre la esencia del gobierno
donald trump entiende que el gobierno es
una oportunidad y que bien conducido
puede ser muy relevante para la sociedad
que tiene que jugar un papel de
liderazgo y por ello lo que propone es
un gobierno más fuerte con una mayor
dosis de autoritarismo que sea capaz de
conducir a la sociedad en un determinado
rumbo por eso lo hice para proteger los
derechos mismos de cruz es todo lo
contrario entiende que el gobierno es en
sí mismo un problema que siempre va a
ser incompetente intrusivo e ineficaz y
que lo que hay que hacer con él es
limitarlo y controlarlo de hecho te cruz
propone eliminar departamentos del
gobierno federal como son el de la
energía el de la educación el de la
vivienda o el comercio porque dice que
esto no son competencias a las que el
gobierno tenga que dedicarse
o también propone por ejemplo introducir
una enmienda a la constitución que
obliga al congreso a aprobar
presupuestos equilibrados para que el
gobierno no pueda hipotecar a las
futuras generaciones con déficit
abultados y deuda de sueldo por eso mi
voto es para ti si es una cuestión de
ahora o nunca
el segundo punto muy ligado al primero
es la política fiscal
donald trump quiere bajar impuestos pero
quiere hacerlo reduciendo tipos y
simplificando en sí mismo la estructura
actual pero manteniéndola sin cambiarla
demasiado
y respecto al gasto público bueno aquí
lo cierto es que es una incógnita porque
donald tran dice que no hace recortes
sociales dice que va a incrementar el
presupuesto de infraestructuras y que
también va a gastar más dinero en
defensa cómo se va a enfrentar al enorme
déficit de la administración americana
bueno nadie lo sabe y de hecho a él
parece tampoco importarle mucho
les cuenta estaremos como empleados que
es cruz en cambio tiene una posición
mucho más consistente con su idea de
gobierno limitado quiere realizar una
auténtica revolución fiscal de hecho
quiere simplificar todos los impuestos
en básicamente dos un tipo único del 10
por ciento sobre ingresos y un impuesto
sobre las transacciones de bienes y
servicios del 19 por ciento algo así
como el iva que conocemos en españa
claro para compensar la pérdida de
ingresos que se derivarían de acabar con
la progresividad fiscal en la
tributación de salarios la tributación
de capitales o en los impuestos
corporativos 10 cruz es firme y dice que
va a eliminar muchísimos medidas de
bienestar social que va a reducir
muchísimo el presupuesto de los
programas sociales y que además también
como decíamos antes va a eliminar muchas
facetas de gobierno donde no tiene por
qué actuar
en lo más profundo de su ser ansían que
un insensible republicano baje los
impuestos torturas a los delincuentes y
sea un dictador
el tercer y último punto es la política
exterior sí es verdad ambos son unos
halcones pero con diferencias donald
trump se muestra un poquito más
pragmático y dice que con la negociación
va a conseguir recuperar la influencia
perdida por los eeuu así se muestra
partidario de un entendimiento con la
rusia de putin o por ejemplo afirma va a
conseguir imponer un acuerdo entre
israelíes y palestinos
y digo imponer porque tram dice que eeuu
tiene que tener la autoridad y la
capacidad para imponerles un acuerdo y
usted en cambio es mucho más firme en
sus posiciones a rusia le contesta con
el concepto reagan ya no de la guerra
fría y respecto a los palestinos con
este que no le importan que él siempre
va a apoyar la democracia realista como
vemos ambos candidatos mantienen
importantes diferencias y si tuviésemos
que describirles podemos hacerlo con una
palabra donald trump ese oportunista que
ha ido cambiando de posiciones políticas
según lo requiriese su nivel de
popularidad
en cambio te cruces el creyente porque
tiene una estrategia decidida de largo
plazo para recuperar lo que él considera
son valores perdidos
ah
de hecho ha sido sorprendente pero el
propio jimmy carter ha dicho que
preferiría a donald trump que ates cruz
porque el primero bueno no es peligroso
es fácil negociar con él pero que el
segundo en cambio es mucho más firme en
sus posiciones estas son las diferencias
de cruz y trump quien conseguirá la
nominación lo veremos